no
[Music]
hell yes
if you don't put her through
you are not only fired from this show
yeah you are not my son anymore Blake
Shelton and Niall Horan's honorary
father-son bond in danger on The Voice
it's as close as you can get to the Real
Deals what threatened the coach's
relationship well team Nile singer Gina
miles's show-stopping performance of
Chris isaak's song Wicked Game
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
yeah Gina had Niles's fellow coach Kelly
Clarkson and even Blake leaping out of
their seats
it's unbelievable Niles got to make a
choice about whether the 19 year old
singer will advance to the semi-finals
that's when Blake started issuing
threats if you don't put her through
you are not only fired from this show
yeah you are not my son anymore tough
love from the country crooner thankfully
Nile took dad's advice and Gina's moving
on King of miles
breaking hearts Across America tore the
roof off this place today
I think that's the biggest thing for me
you know like a lot there's a lot of
serious
you know technical singers on this show
and I just want to make sure that they
enjoy it as much as they you know enjoy
hitting the notes and all that kind of
stuff it's uh
it's an amazing experience a show like
this as for Blake and Nile's tight Bond
it started early in the season
feeling like a father-son top bond with
Nile there you go mostly because he
disappoints me a lot so good to meet you
I think it's better to meet you hey
that's just another thing that she and I
have in common I love you too thank you
Dad oh you're already taking the my
father-in-like son huh and like most
parent kid relationships they bicker but
Papa always knows best I mean oh my God
that was my favorite thing that I've
heard in a long time
I still have Goosebumps from the
performance you're absolutely near the
genome
foreign
[Music]